hello this is Ori here sitting with
David Perlman hello Rory hello David
thanks for joining me and if it just did
his interview with Alan he definitely
check it out and now I'm sitting here
with him and we're here to explore I'm
very excited to see what this is gonna
be like great
me too
but what if we're not entertaining if
our pace is slow
sometimes I talk too much I guess this
isn't one of those times I'm taking my
cues from you
[Music]
and so in addition to the work that
you're doing now you've developed
yourself quite a bit did you say that
you were into meditation type stuff for
10 years more like 20 for a personal
practice but I was at the University of
Wisconsin in Richie Davidson's lab for
10 years yeah almost exactly 10 years
beautiful doing research on mindfulness
and other forms of meditation mm-hmm
you know the lab is still going strong
they just keep getting better and better
they have a lot of things going on right
now as the Center for healthy minds and
Richard Davidson a lot of interesting
things going on there still mm-hmm
what's the most yes well what I was
gonna say is that the part what I ended
up by the end the part that I was most
interested in was the the identity part
because you know in traditional Buddhist
teachings they talk a lot about
meditation being for the purpose of
recognizing the nature of the self and
how it is always in flux and when you
see the nature as itself this is what
people talk about now with identity like
all the things that make you who you are
and that you think of as the story of
yourself
so my dissertation research kind of
looked at that kind of stuff great I
also kind of led me into the
the social media and the misinformation
and because of the way that you know one
of the big ways that you control people
is by you say things to them and then it
becomes a part of their identity their
sort of tribal identity affiliation with
a particular group and then once it's
become a part of the identity then
people are unwilling to revalue
reevaluate those beliefs like it's sort
of fixed and unchangeable at that point
and then it really you know becomes a
part of people's day-to-day choices
identity identity identity I did say
that a lot yeah it's true it's important
it's important yeah
so we're here to in the broader sense
we're here to play with identity we're
here to explore identity
what identity are you inspired to play
with my thoughts on it are that the most
important thing is recognizing that
identity is transient or that's just you
know rephrasing sort of buddhist
teachings you know the self is
impermanent and always changing and when
if people start to really define
themselves in terms of very fixed things
where there's no room for you know
there's no room for any like air to get
in around the cracks or something like
that that can lead to all kinds of
problems many different kinds of
problems you know and people identify
very strongly with some in group versus
some out group you know regardless of
what those groups are that kind of
tribalism doesn't usually lead to really
good behavior
yeah and it's tricky because one of the
easiest ways to sort of teach people or
encourage people to treat someone with
kindness is to think of that particular
person as being family or a part of your
in-group or a part of your tribe or you
know a team affiliation or whatever and
it creates this camaraderie but the
problem is that then you're also doing
that at the expense of the opposition to
the other then you're sort of having the
opposite effect in the other direction
so for instance there's a very classic
philosophically Laden sci-fi novel
called Starship Troopers by Robert
Heinlein and one of the many challenging
themes in the book is he I think he
thinks that he is describing a utopian
future where all of humanity
on earth is all united in a common
purpose but the only way that that
happens in the book is because we
encounter hostile aliens who are trying
to kill us so then we're at war but
everyone on earth is all in it together
and so then they kind of band together
with the sense of community and family
but that's like okay I don't think that
like alien space war is the best
solution for us all to get along yeah
wow that's interesting so who's cooler
me or you well I just met you today so I
don't really know I hang out with a lot
of young hip people so I feel really
uncool all the time because you know
young people are cooler than old people
obviously we got Alan greening honestly
I'm afraid that Alan is actually cooler
than both of us yeah what a question
who's cooler out of us yeah I suppose
that's a little unfair for me to punt
that one to a third party it's almost
like what I was saying a minute ago well
the only way you and I can find common
ground is if he's the one that's cooler
and we're on the same level
yes what if this creation makes us all
cool he probably feels that way yeah I
guess I did say that all of creation is
what I think the most beautiful thing is
I guess I feel like is cool the same as
Beauty mm-hmm that's kind of that's not
really a profound question I take it
back we have to cheer on in a line with
Beauty for real but do we have to cheer
on and align with coolness I don't know
what I think about that yeah I have
mixed feelings some of my feelings are
cool and some of them are not so cool
yes so what about you what do you think
the most beautiful thing is hard
question and I struggled with that one
think that the most beautiful thing is
lessons of love and wisdom landed in the
flesh shared in the world yeah I like
that
I think I guess my mind kind of went to
a particular idea of beauty but at the
sort of abstract like spiritual level of
beauty I do feel like that like the the
lessons the spiritual lessons do I get
to revise my answer thing yeah like the
lessons yeah I mean I kind of like that
story that I told at the end I guess I
could have even told that story is a
part of the beauty thing I also yeah
another cool thing is your gaze yeah I
notice I wasn't sure if it was my gaze
or your gaze I noticed it too there are
just moments in connecting with you
where I'm captivated by your pupils in
your eye it's like I can't even say why
it's just like it grabs me it's like
pure interestingness the color of this
iris I think is quite unique as well I'm
gonna try and get a quick zoom on it
actually let's see let's see you know
there is a good zoom on it what is that
color do you know what color those are I
think it's GRU
hey what's GRU mean green and blue oh
look it up it's a classic philosophical
sort of thought experiment okay great I
don't even remember what the lesson of
the guru story is now that I think about
it I just remember reading at some time
a long time ago yeah I don't know the
gaze thing is interesting too you know
there's a the dyad meditation when you
hang out in meditation world and
mindfulness and all this stuff and you
go to retreats and the different people
are teaching different techniques now
these things going on yeah some of the
people will do like a wider range of
different kinds of exercises and not
just like plain old you know sitting
meditation and just like having two
people sit facing each other and look
into each other's eyes it you know it's
it sounds like it's kind of hard you
just say that to someone and they're
like yeah but then when you actually do
it if you also have experience with
meditation what's interesting is that
you're like whoa that kind of like makes
some of this happen
like take some of the effort out of it I
don't it doesn't necessarily always
click but there is something about it
yeah I think maybe part of the reason
why sometimes people have a hard time
making eye contact because it definitely
does do something yeah I don't think
anyone's really studied that you know
there's all this research on mindfulness
but a lot of these sort of other I guess
that you might call more minor practices
in the meditation world they don't have
the same kind of research focus yeah so
who knows are we really one you said
about the gaze I was thinking oh there
was a film that came out like 10 years
ago called one where the thesis of this
documentary guy was a we're all one and
then like one of the you know it's like
bits and pieces all over he's actually
Fievel who talks that people who talk to
these other people but one of the like
biggest parts of the film was a human
interviewed Bob Thurman yes you know
like a Buddhist teacher guy whatever
right and they had this whole thing and
then he was like I don't even remember
like he asked him some question and then
so that in the movie there's like the
camera showing the two of them talking
and they asked him some question right
and then Bob is like looking him right
into the eyes and like does a gaze thing
and then there's this like longtime of
them just gazing into each other's eyes
but in the when you're watching the
movie they're like cutting from that to
like the camera which obviously means
that that's looking at the camera and
not looking at the interviewer right so
when I saw it the director was there and
he told the story of that event and how
like they got he they just sort of like
film like that and then he was just like
lost in his gaze and then later
afterwards he was like can we go back to
that place and film some more footage
where you look into the camera because I
need that to be able to put it into the
movie so then they recreated it like
that
and then there's like a little scene
after well let me ask you this okay
we're one then how would I know
if it's the truth and it doesn't matter
if you know
uh-huh
which I suppose given the line of
business I'm in I should probably put in
a disclaimer which is that that doesn't
necessarily go for mundane truths like
who but like what is or is not actually
in the basement of a piece of restaurant
what does a person who have become this
realization be like myself have been
practicing Tibetan Buddhism for a long
time
they sure do have a lot of stories about
that in Tibetan Buddhism and they have
like you know rainbow body and they have
our Hut's and they have did you know
that this what's a rainbow body if I can
pause you in ask in some of the
traditions of Tibetan Buddhism there's
the idea that when someone finally
achieves full and complete enlightenment
than they do this final meditation where
the body dissolves into light and then
there's just nothing left except the
hair and the fingernails and then I
that's like you can find that written
down anywhere like if you just google
rainbow body to talk about that
recently I learned from talking to some
tibetan lamas that apparently the the
the dogma or the doctrine or whatever
says well technically the did you know
yogi or ho or they didn't have to leave
behind hair and fingernails but they do
that just you know to provide some
relics for the people left behind so
they have some sort of evidence or
something yeah can focus on so it's just
kind of like a thank you gift or party
if we the idea of just the body
dissolving into light it's funny because
then I've also read other people talking
about sort of obvious parallels with
psychedelic experiences where people can
feel like they are dissolving into light
or something like that but then
obviously you don't in fact disappear
just because you like drop a bunch of
acid
like you're dissolving into light right
so then who knows in Buddhism like maybe
it was all is one of these things a lot
of religions where they like wrote it as
a metaphor originally and then later
people started to take it literally a
you know we get to achieve rainbow body
my guess would be no especially because
of what I just said of I'm not entirely
convinced that it wasn't just a metaphor
anyway but you know if I got to see it
that would be pretty cool yes
if I got to be it then that would be
pretty cool I feel like the focus on
enlightenment is sometimes a problem
because all I really want to see is
people not being a dick unless there's a
really good reason for it that's my
favorite mm-hmm yeah and then of course
you know you could if you were you could
asked me to define my terms be a tough
one
and not being a dick you say yeah it's
sort of like the Dalai Lama says my
religion is kindness but you can't the
Dalai Lama wouldn't say it the way I
said it that's not really his it would
be off-brand for the Dalai Lama to say
don't be a dick
okay sometimes I'm kind of a dick my
friends tell me usually when I'm driving
what's better better feeling like you're
one with everybody and everything or
owning your [ __ ] and being humble better
for yourself or better for everyone else
cuz the latter is definitely better for
everyone else there was this a there
used to be this blog called the last
psychiatrist and he had one about
narcissistic personality disorder or he
talked about how he would treat someone
and he like describes what the
conversation is and the person's like
how is that gonna help me get better and
the answer is oh you're not doing it for
you you're doing it for everyone else
that's kind of the point then like if
you get to the point where you're
capable of making a decision to do
something where the point is for
everyone else then that's the big step
especially if someone had been diagnosed
with narcissistic personality forever
even for just anyone in general like for
people to do things like yeah I feel
like that would just be the right thing
to do or the better thing to do versus
like what's in it for me I don't know
the right thing to do
yeah that's a loaded phrase - yes it's
almost like you start talking about
these things and like every single word
of every sentence is a rabbit hole you
can go down just which is great because
this means that the philosophers still
have jobs after you know four thousand
years or whatever
Allen where'd you go
just taking some notes on the episode
and writing some thoughts in the
comments to the viewers hey everyone
thanks for tuning in
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and we'll talk about it we'll
talk about it on the show some of the
notes that I've taken so far are about
the dyad meditation the importance of
sitting and looking at someone's eyes
for extended periods of time and seeing
the divinity and the God within each
other and orey's questions about are we
really one and if we are really one how
would I know
good questions owning your own [ __ ] and
being humble and being one my religion
being kindness focusing on not being a
dick it was a nice recap is that going
out alive yeah well that's very meta
yeah yeah actually I'll let you know if
peeps comment we have uh viewers
watching live so let us know your
thoughts guys hey hey live viewers you
guys hi I'm wondering if you're hi out
there
why why why do you wonder that well this
does seem like the kind of thing that
someone might find themselves drawn to
if they're lucky
I just I had a thought I wonder just
that you know I was telling about the
documentary and the Bob Sherman thing I
wonder I wonder if I gaze at the camera
if that works
wow it's really not the same yeah it is
so not the same as looking at a person
but what if I just pretend
but if you've already meditated for 20
years are you ever gonna open your heart
again yeah overrated I'm just messing
with you I don't know I don't know what
do you mean by that are you saying that
all that meditation is gonna close off
my heart this is a jab at CEOs who
meditate well people in general in the
Silicon Valley and it's great oh
wakening in the culture of people
influencers and cool people there's a I
wish I could be an influencer yeah well
you're on the show so there's this
aspect of people who have realized
something or meditate where they're like
free or something one of the things I
learned from not just like practicing
meditation and going meditation retreats
but like getting into this meditation
and science community is it like okay it
gives you a different cross-section of
the community and I realized that there
are plenty of people who practice
meditation who are not that great and in
fact one of my fellow grad students
published a really good paper I think it
made it into a paper or maybe it was
just a conference abstract but she
looked at some data and basically kind
of had this hypothesis that some of the
people we were looking at who were
Americans who are really really serious
about meditation practice they're
actually scoring worse on certain
psychological measures but they were
getting better over too
so she sort of had this suggestion like
hey maybe if somebody in America decides
to get really serious about meditation
maybe for at least some of those people
it's because they got problems and
they're looking for solutions whereas
you know in some other country people
just you know they just send their kids
to the monastery or whatever it's just
like a cultural norm and yeah I guess
for me the main reaction that I had to
her findings on that was yeah I guess I
feel like I started meditation because I
was messed up so seems seems legit I
don't know but there's also you know
just people there's a classic text
called words of my perfect teacher and
one of the things in there they talk
about is how the practice of meditation
softens up your mind like rubbing oil
into leather
but yeah the leather the leather of a
butter horn because in ancient Tibet one
of the standard things that they had was
a taker they would have liked a little
crescent moon thing yeah made out of
leather and they'd filled with butter in
that yak butter and then they would sew
it up and then they would have like a
whole bunch of those strewn along the
side of their horse for long travels
because seriously they did not have a
lot of choices when it come to food in
Tibet and leather crescents filled with
butter who is one of their best bets but
then they you know they kick around they
take the butter out and then they reuse
it as a butter container and after a
while the leather gets really stiff so
with that context this teaching is like
but if the leathers too stiff from
butter then more oil isn't gonna help
and you definitely after a while you
start to see some people where they just
like like one of the I didn't recognize
it early on but this guy that I knew
that was a yoga teacher he like had this
real heart-to-heart with me in he had a
wife and a kid and he was like I really
resent my family for taking away from my
meditation time I just wish they weren't
there
and I'm like whoa dude you got you got
problems with your meditation practice
and I think maybe you might want to fall
back on the don't be a dick
principal is it still makes me sad to
think about it actually
what do you think gallon
meditation softens your mind like
rubbing oil into leather but the leather
can't be too stiff from not having any
oil for a long time no no if the leather
is too stiff from having too much oil
all leather oh oh interesting but what a
[ __ ] would it be both then that if you
never oil to soften the mind but also if
you boil it to write much about
interesting what do you think about that
who cares that's a good answer
you know because that's kind of the
point is easy to get just like
obsessively intellectual about anything
even just meditation and then you're
just it's just another obsession which
is not helpful yeah these days
I'm alive about being meditative in the
world and meditative izing the world so
there's like a traction goal there's
like a real transpersonal change impulse
that's kind of the opposite of the
extractive attention the economy yeah
beautiful
yet there is this movement where our
systems my in our hierarchies might
empower something new
go on we are all in a sense bound to our
webs of relationship dynamics and
hierarchies but if at the top of those
things
kourin quote running our webs is
something just I'm holding myself back
from making a Stephen King joke
something balanced and sensitive and
developed then we have a next world
amen
next world
that's the vision and thank you and you
and you for hearing and thank you your
walk
a couple comments angela is watching
again lul I always chuckle when Horry is
on he is so intense with this silent
presence a big Reggie also comments
could you ask David if he is a freemason
no I am NOT a freemason but what's
interesting is that this whole thing
with our we D in a simulation obviously
relates to Gnosticism and the
foundations of Freemasonry and of course
that's what the Matrix movie was about
and the terminology was taken from
Freemasonry and references to Gnosticism
so I mean I think you know you got a
thing where like whatever culture people
are in they're gonna use the the
language and the you know the ideas and
the mythology of that culture to talk
about the ideas that they have you know
so if you you know if your mythology is
like here's what the names of the gods
are then you might be like oh are we
really living in the mind of Brahma and
if you are living in this world where
everything's all about computers you
might be like oh are we living in a
computer simulation or like you know if
you're a nonstick heretic a few hundred
years ago or whenever it was you might
be like oh are we you know living in the
mind of whatever I mean I guess I'll
probably get it wrong if you're asking
that question you probably know more
about it than I do so I just won't try
to mess up the details but no I am NOT
personally I mean I did Buddhist
meditation for a really really long time
before I finally just started saying
okay fine I'm a Buddhist and it was
really just like it was just at the
point where people are like dude you
hang out with Buddhists you do
stuff you go to meditation retreats with
Buddhist teachers you do this you like
every week and I'm like okay fine I'm a
Buddhist
are you happy now but I don't know it's
very easy to turn that into an identity
too and then you're like hey look at me
I'm going around Silicon Valley wearing
privies what we need is to be
evolutionary together
that's the coolest identity mmm does
that mean survival of the fittest well
you can just say no I think that's not
what you meant a big Reggie says haha I
love your show
I love that Horry be evolutionary
together continue hi big red G big G
thanks for the comment brother yes
hi Angela also by the way don't you to
feel left out
yeah yeah thank you for greeting our
viewers and I recognize these names -
they're not one-timers yeah and they're
just here yesterday they're part of the
movement cool well what is that movement
Ori
the movement to become an enlightened
civilization sure good yeah by 2035 2035
hmm
why what happens in 2035 well this guy I
like had that particular vision this guy
I like his name if I may share his
Benton yo Massaro so maybe he can come
hang out and collaborate here in the Bay
Area
anything else alive for you before we
wrap up
now I think I'm ready for lunch
it's been an interesting morning great
well thank you for joining me thank you
for having me okay um and big Reggie
says hello David I'm curious what's the
significance and meaning of your coat
looks very snazzy
[Music]
so the first talk that I gave to a
military audience was a Naval
Postgraduate School in Monterey and then
I was hanging out with my host out there
and we're walking down the street and we
walked past a goodwill and I saw this
coat in the window there and it fit
perfectly and it was really cheap
because it was a goodwill so I bought it
and now it's kind of my like talking
about this information good luck jacket
I believe this is ostrich in which a
friend who's way more fashionable than
me told me that uh sure skin is totally
out of style now and people used to
think it's cool but now it's totally not
cool but I guess as a thing that is as
my misinformation good luck jacket I
think I can hopefully get a pass on
being up-to-the-minute on the fashion
choices he says very cool haha so thanks
for sharing
excellent yeah so Alan now are we good
to wrap up yeah all right cool thanks
everybody for tuning in and we'll see
you soon
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below